[Music]
so yeah thank you so much my name is
Todd it matters and with my colleague
Kirsten Hanson we both machine-learning
engineers we work at X kernel and we
encountered this problem as a machine
learning team on how to train the
machine learning jobs how to scale this
how to manage these jobs how to make
things as smooth as possible for machine
learning teams so we had the right
hardware and we had the people who are
doing the modeling but we couldn't
really figure out how to do the
organization in a proper way and that's
where it could be neatest came in as a
good tool to manage these kind of jobs
so the aim of this talk is not to
introduce kubernetes so I'll be touching
upon some of the interesting features
like this scheduler and that's the main
feature that we'll be focusing on from
cuban eaters and when it won't be really
covering the internals of tensorflow
so we'd like to be as framework agnostic
as possible so these concepts should
apply to any of the other frameworks
that people use with deep learning
frameworks or other machine learning
tools so the whole idea is how to manage
and scale these jobs so basically how to
automate the pipeline to fire these jobs
Turtles somewhere and make the training
process as smooth as possible but before
we start I'd like to take a step
backward and start by what tech screen
is actually doing so as some of you know
Tech's kernel is doing solutions in the
HR domain so we're parsing Seavey's
we're parsing vacancies and we're
matching both together so the whole idea
is based on sequence labeling problems
and as you see here we have a PDF a
typical CV I would like to have this
nice data structure that contains or
information that people use afterwards
as recruiters in search engines and so
on so we have a lot of machine learning
jobs based on tensor flow and we have
this new wave of deep learning models
based on by Alice TMS and this these are
basically tons of flow implementation
and we support a lot of languages like
18 languages I think we even more and we
have a core machine learning team of 13
engineers doing these training jobs
regularly and each language it's not
actually one model it's a stack of
models so we have
I don't know I think six models per
language so as you might have guessed we
have hundreds of tens of loads off the
train and let's start by defining what
is a real world machine learning system
so this is something that we also
encountered that we kind of simplifying
what data scientists are doing so we
have this nice machine learning block
where we do the actual modeling but in
fact we also have a lot of other things
to care about like the data verification
like the resource management process
management and so on and I kind of want
to differentiate between let's say the
left part we do the preparation the part
in the middle where we do the training
and then on the right we do the serving
and I think yesterday there was a talk
about how to monitor these models in
production but that's not really the
focus of this talk we're kind of
focusing now on the resource management
like the hardware management and Process
Management so how to do this during the
training part during the training phase
so as a machine learning engineer as a
data scientist I don't want to really
babysit my jobs I want someone to take
care of this for me
and this is where I gain communities
come in so what is it all about we want
to have separation of concerns so
machine learning modeling should be
different than machining operations I
mean people can do both people can know
how to do both but ideally the data
scientist shouldn't really worry about
what's happening under the hood so as a
data scientist if I have a tensor
photograph and I have a config file in
my hand I would like to send this to
some back box that would run my compute
intensive training job in a convenient
manner and that's the whole point
so as easy as possible which means with
the least possible steps but also as
fast as possible so how can I utilize my
hardware how can I make use of the
hardware we have as a team take a
picture so the whole talk is what do you
need to have in this black box what do
we care about so first fact more CPUs
for us we're the tensor flow graphs that
we've been using meant faster epics
so doubling the CPUs almost got us half
the time pair POC and that's why we
wanted to scale outside of your laptop
you want to go to some other scalable
Hardware one of the fact is the hardware
is there as we mentioned but the
question would be how do you organize
this usage between
scientists and the hardware and the
machines so this is how one Alex like
sketch out the talk we have how we did
it before cue bonitas like and what kind
of headaches did we encounter and then
we're going to define what kubernetes is
again not as an entire framework but
rather what we're interested in and then
we go a bit into the details of how to
manage these jobs how to scale these
jobs and so on so let's start by before
cue benítez what actually happened what
was the case beforehand so I'd like to
formally this problem as the typical
machine hunt as we call it so we have
this cluster of virtual machines that we
own as a team and then we have this data
scientist who we'd called Ouija in this
case I think is not here today
so we do want to train his machine
learning model right and he wants to
find a machine where he can train this
model the question would be which one we
have different specs per machine some
machines have more core some machines
have typical general purpose machines
and so on so the question is how do we
check which machine to run on that's one
question and the other question is is it
actually free or is it being utilized
and if it's free then I can start my job
so I was shot with the first one but
it's actually busy so this is the manual
steps that we've been going through
beforehand and then we check some other
machines and they're still busy until I
find one which is free and then I go in
there I schedule my job so in this case
if you have another data scientist who
want to use also these machines this
cluster in this case it's not possible
because all of them are busy so only she
would have to wait in this case she's
also not here so that's as you might
have guessed we are in desperate need of
a proper scheduler so that's the whole
point so that's one step the next step
is okay we found the Machine we want to
start things now we want to start a new
job what are the steps so that we G can
start his nice job on this machine so
okay the typical steps that we do with
SSH create the Condor environment pull
some code pull the data start the job
these are usually beforehand they were
basically manual steps so that wasn't
really scalable in that case because for
one person that's fine but if you have
an entire team that would like to do
this in an automated manner that wasn't
really possible so yeah a lot of steps
so where the problem is what
actually the problem in this case so we
have a lot of data scientists we have a
big machine learning team that we want
to enable in order to train this models
in a smooth way and the machine specs
are not only standardized as I mentioned
so some of them have 40 cores others
have 8 cores and so on and I'd like to
utilize these machines and the other
scientists don't always train single
model at a time so I'm not sure who's
training what and are we training a lot
of models no models one model so these
kind of questions I don't want to worry
about this I want to automate this
process so more data scientists more
models cage running is a heart that's
the main problem that we have so the
reality reality is again we have a lot
of data scientists a lot of machines
with different specs and we need an
intermediate layer to choose the right
machine but also prepare the environment
start money to the jobs and baby seed
these jobs may be said these jobs in the
sense of if one of these jobs failed how
can I restart this automatically without
worrying about where can I do this and
how can I do that and this is where q
Benitez came in soku Benitez was a nice
tool that we were actually using for
other purposes like server micro
services running CI ICD jobs and so on
and we thought it's a perfect that's a
perfect use case for it actually so what
is kubernetes yeah this actual being
just an interesting question who knows
what could be neat this is cool who
trained models on communities before
okay like for so for those of you who
know what communities is I'll just be
focusing as I mentioned on a scheduler
and of course we have this mainstream
definition that it's a container
orchestration framework of course but
what does that actually mean so let's
imagine that we have a cluster alright
you have some nodes and these nodes have
communities installed on so it's a
framework that manages these nodes this
cluster the idea is that I can actually
give labels to these machines so I can
say label node number one of type
machine learning which means that node
number one can hold machine learning
workloads so why is this useful because
then I can make this scheduler know
which machines to use according to the
workloads I'm getting so if I know that
that's a CI C D job it doesn't really
have a priority so run it and
creating machine well that's a micro
service and it requires some sort of
specs then I know why to run this
because then I can tell the scheduler
what kind of machine to run on and this
doesn't have to be the case so if you
didn't tell the scheduler what to do in
the sense of labeling these machines it
will still figure out which notes to
rank and accordingly scheduled the
containers so you have jobs as
containers and in this case these jobs
are our tensor flow containers so they
contain the tensor flow graph with the
environment with the condo environment
install dependencies and everything
there it's basically ready to start so
it's ready to be run on kubernetes and
then I have a scheduler in between that
would choose among these machines which
one do you want to use in order to run
one of these containers so the question
here is what is the scheduling criteria
what do I need to worry about so one
thing which nodes has machine learning
labeled so as I mentioned we labeled
these machines according to the specs
and then I asked okay which of them has
the label machine learning that I can
use to schedule this job that's one
thing the other thing is again out of
these ml nodes which of these are being
utilized
so remember Luigi when he was trying to
find a machine the whole point well
which of these machines is actually
empty right now and I'll go a bit into
the details further on why we need these
machines to be empty because a very
basic question might be why not just
schedule two jobs on the same machine
and the answer is because we can figure
tensorflow to utilize all of the CPUs on
the same machine so if you give it 40
cores then the flow will just take the
whole machine like the entire 40 cores
to train the jobs and that's why we
didn't want to jobs to be on the same
machine to compete for resources and
then schedule basically the next
container on the next three machine
learning node if I found none I will
basically queue these and the scheduler
is also doing the queuing for us so we
don't have to worry about when to
schedule these of their being killed so
it periodically asks the machines if
they're free and accordingly it will do
the scheduling okay so one other way to
view kubernetes
is it's basically an abstraction layer
between your hardware and whatever you
want to run so as I mentioned we Orien
Jenkins exact
we ran desk workers we ran micro
services or tens of Lowe jobs so
communities doesn't really care what is
it running in most cases so it only ran
containers right so it doesn't really
care what's inside these containers and
that's the good thing about it that you
can have multiple workloads of different
types running on the same machine
cluster not machine assuming of course
that we did the kind of scheduling
constraints that we viewed here so
that's why we needed these constraints
to make sure that these workloads can
peacefully run together in the same
cluster so that was one thing on how to
define like what kind of features are we
interested in from communities itself
and then the next question would be how
did we manage these jobs how do we
overcome the problems the manual steps
that we've been through before so in
order to do this we need two things one
of them is the docker file which is
basically the definition of the
container and the other thing is the
community's config which is basically a
deployment file that we use in order to
tell queue bonitas what to do in this
case so what should be the scheduling
constraints what should be the
scheduling features that we interested
in to run this job so let's start with
the docker file it's actually pretty
basic so you have the repo which you
basically pull actually can go to the
universe script right away and in this
case you cloned the tensor flow graph
alongside the config file that you have
you install the dependencies and then
you basically start the tuning now the
main question would be why did I do the
cloning on run time instead of build
time and the answer is well it doesn't
really matter because if we have three
days of training if I spent one minute
pulling and running the dependencies it
won't really make a huge difference
that's one thing and the other thing is
I didn't want to build a new docker
image every time I have a change in my
tensor flow graph so in this case I can
only have one docker image for all types
of tens of tens of flow graphs that I'm
training so the next thing is the
kubernetes config
so first thing is we will pull the image
so I now push this image as online
training I gave it some version and the
next thing will be how to run this
container how do i anything could be
Anita's right so I pull the container so
in the definition I tell could be need
to switch container to one that's one
thing the next thing is the affinities
remember the two constraints that we
mentioned that no pods no two containers
can co-occur within the same machine and
we're interested in the machine of type
machine learning so scheduler only one
can run one training job on one node at
a time so in this case I said ok I'm
interested in all jobs of type iron and
training which is basically the type of
the container I'm running and then here
Asset pod anti affinity which basically
means don't run so that's a negation
basically so don't run these jobs
together on the same host because again
I configure tensorflow
to consume all CPU so I don't want them
to Corker and compete for resources so
that's one thing another thing is please
run on machine type machine learning so
basically these are the constraints or
these are the features I'm interested in
in order to run this container this job
on kubernetes of course I stripped away
a lot of details but this doesn't really
matter for this talk I think it's
outside of the context but we're only
interested again in these two
constraints so what's actually happening
there so we have now the locker file we
have the kubernetes deployment and now
we'd like to schedule this somewhere so
I separated this into three contexts one
of them is the local context which is
your laptop or your station whatever
that is and then you have Jenkins which
is doing the actual building and then
communities which one's the workload or
the machine learning job so you have a
tensor flow graph you have the conflict
file as we mentioned you push the gate
lab and the rest is basically automated
so whatever happens behind the scenes is
automated and that was the whole point
behind using this setup so we have one
job which pulls in the docker file that
we just mentioned and builds the docker
image and this also contains again the
dependencies it pulls the tensor flow
graph and it knows how to start this job
we build a locker image that we push to
a docker registry and then this is
pulled by kubernetes alongside a config
file a deployment file in order to start
this on queue bonitas so remember the
two resources that we have we had in
mind so the docker file the cabinet is
config these are basically consumed by
these two jobs in order to start the
training so everything beyond pushing to
get lab in this case is automated so the
question here comes what's actually
happening here so again remember the two
scheduling constraints we have machine
learning machine that has to be labeled
with machine learning that's one thing
and the other thing machine can only run
one job at a time so let's demonstrate
this so you have Jenkins which just
scheduled a job to kubernetes and then
we have this cluster with different
machines with different types and then
the question would be what actually
happens behind the scenes how is the
scheduling being done so we try to
schedule on node number two because this
is the node which is labeled with
machine learning but then it's busy so
it's basically the same thing that we
encountered before we try the next one
and again it's busy so what happens is
communities does the queuing for us so
it will just wait and checks for the
next time until it's free like I don't
know every 10 seconds every 30 seconds I
think it's actually configurable so you
can edit these parameters and then once
it's ready it will basically schedule
this job there and fetch the image and
these machines are connected to a data
source so to pull the data from and then
write back the logs so if you have a
tensor board URL that you'd like to
access and if you'd like to point this
to some data store in order to access
the logs and see your accuracies
performance and so on this is how you do
it so to recap this part what we did was
basically get push as a data scientist
and then the black box was doing the
rest for us so we managed to set up the
environment which was P built as a
blocker image we managed to rely on
kubernetes
scheduling features to run and start the
job and one thing also which is
interesting to keep in mind
we have everything documented so we have
the locker files the deployment files
everything is in get in this case so we
can reproduce whatever the data
scientist has just did and if these
models are versioned then we have we can
backtrack the whole process basically
which is also interesting for us I think
as a machine learning community and the
last part I'd like to focus on is the
actual scaling so how can we utilize the
or distribute work among different
machines how is this actually possible
and why do I want to do this because I
want faster training so the previous
part was automating the process but then
the next part would be how can I utilize
more of these machines how can I make
sure that the training is actually
faster and that all of these machines
are being utilized so one case that we
had in mind is and also it was an easy
win I would say was hyper parameter
tuning so we all know there's a data
scientist okay have a tensor flow graph
that you'd like to run but in fact
you're also doing a parameter tuning
which means that you get set of
parameters and then you start different
tones with distinct set of parameters so
the question would be how can I schedule
these separately how can I make
kubernetes aware of these separately to
start them on different machines so
beforehand we had everything as one job
so the whole process was being executed
in one job and tuning was sequential so
communities who start this job I started
by the first graph I trained it I'm done
I moved to the next one and so on so it
was basically sequential and in this
case we didn't really utilize as much as
we could in this case so the question
was what if I can distribute these runs
among different machines so we embedded
or actually still work-in-progress to it
now embedding the Harper family training
logic within the kubernetes scheduler so
how that is done communities as an API
that everyone can use and the scheduler
has an API so you can write your own
scheduler in 10 lines of bash and it
also has a really nice Python client
that you can use so given the tuning
logic that we had and given this Python
client we managed also to write a
scheduler that can know where and when
to run the next tune run on a separate
so in this case we broke apart the job
into different tune ones as we called
them and then each of these is running
on a separate machine and then in this
case they're running in parallel so
beforehand it was just one big chunk and
now I managed to separate these by
letting communities know how to do the
high parameter tuning so that's one part
the next part could be so if you're
running distributed tens of flow there's
a really nice tool called cue flow that
can actually do this for you so this
however has to your code needs to
support that so you need to write
distributed tons of flow code in order
to be able to separate the graph among
different workers and that's kind of it
depends also on your architecture so
this didn't really apply for us as a
starting point so the tuning was
actually faster in this case but
assuming that you have distributed
tensorflow
and you'd like to separate the graph
among different nodes this is possible
by using cue flow so to recap again what
we did was separating the concerns so
machine learning from machine hearing
operations data scientist doing modeling
and the operations is being done
automatically behind the scenes by using
tools like docker kubernetes and Jenkins
to do the scheduling to fire these jobs
and managing environments using
kubernetes because these environments
are pre-built as docker images as we
defined and you can have reproduce
ability in the sense of you can trace
back what happened by checking and get
what the data scientists have just
pushed and what Jenkins has just
scheduled and communities and finally we
check the scalable solutions so we have
the a parameter tuning which is possible
and also key flow which separates the
tensor flow graph among different nodes
so in this case you have scalable
solutions as well to have to utilize
more hardware that's it
thank you
thank you so much strike and we have
time for some questions yes thank you
for the talk I have a question can you
elaborate a little more on parameter
tuning yes specifically do you use
something like hyper opt or any other
library that could be sort of flagged in
because you could specify a whole
subspace of so in this case it was a
basic grid search that we implemented
and what we did instead of so you have a
set of parameters and then you know what
to start next but by starting next it
was basically scheduled the next job in
cribben eaters that's the whole
difference but the actual logic is the
same that you will implement in any
other setup any more questions
yes hi how do you handle credentials
from the accessing databases for
instance we don't how do compare this
visa I'm Erin gee the Google cloud
emerging I think it's pretty similar in
this and in theory like in principle but
in this case we didn't want to get
resort to cloud providers for legal
reasons so we did this locally but I
think it's pretty comparable have you
thought about using aq work here in Cuba
Nettie's in order to scale the jobs just
gain the jobs so what do you mean like
there is a queue and worker in
kubernetes so then some someone can pick
up the jobs and you can yes but in this
case you need also someone to consume
these jobs in this case so in this case
we didn't have like a consumer and a
publisher like this setup wasn't really
there it's just a tensor flow model that
needs to be trained somewhere so it was
a matter of actually starting the job
instead of having someone consuming an
actual message
are you doing anything with respect to
job priority to prevent someone from
hugging the cluster so not yet yeah the
question is basically about priority so
starting version one point ten in
kubernetes there's also you can give
priorities to pods so if this gives you
the ability to do preemption for example
so to evict pods if they have less
priority so we didn't do this yet but
it's supported hi maybe I miss it in my
toilet break but the cluster size is
that also handled by Q bonitas that like
the amount of capacity capacity that you
have to schedule jobs so the cluster
size is fixed so you have some machines
which are basically there that's how you
set up the cluster I think there are
some new solutions to auto scale this as
well so like any elastic computing
cluster basically so to include machines
on demand any more questions
so you mentioned tensor board is it like
one service somewhere outside like a
separate pods it goes like the true
elastic volume or do you have a service
like for every pot separately so how you
can do it just let me get back so how
you can do it is if this data source is
connected to your machine you can start
engine board locally so that's one thing
and one other thing that we thought
about is deploying this as a service
inside communities itself and then you
can expose this and data scientists can
access this with the world but we don't
get locally for now because we have
access to the same data source okay any
more questions
okay so let's give a very warm
[Applause]